[Music]
hey everyone welcome to another
installment of Harry Potter Theory today
we'll be discussing the history of one
of the most infamous spells known to The
Wizarding World the cruciatus curse and
its incantation crucio for those of you
who may not know the cruciata's curse is
one of three of The Wizarding world's
most formidable spells which have come
to be known as the unforgivable curses
alongside the cruciatus curse this Trio
of unforgivable curses is made up of the
killing curse and the imperia's curse
with the most fatal curse and therefore
likely the most well-known being the
killing curse which is also known by its
incantation Avada Kedavra outside of the
unforgivable curses Avatar kadavra may
also be the most well-known spell in the
entire Harry Potter Universe due to its
horrifyingly memorable usage throughout
the series after all this is the
incantation used by Lord Voldemort to
murder Harry's parents Jane in Lily
Potter it's also the spell used in the
Dark Lord's attempt to kill Harry
himself not once but twice the first of
these failed murder attempts occurring
when the killing curse infamously
bounced back at Voldemort resulting in
the demise of his first Reign of Power
in the 1970s and early 80s the Avada
cadav recurs once again went to Rye when
Voldemort tried to kill Harry with it
during the Battle of Hogwarts almost two
decades later
the imperius curse on the other hand is
arguably the least dark Anonymous spell
of the three cast by uttering the
incantation imperio this curse is used
to essentially possess another person
and control their actions so while
certainly not a good spell it doesn't
cause physical harm in the same way the
other two do which I guess makes it less
terrifying and therefore less memorable
this of course brings us to the third
and final spell of the unforgivable
cursors and the one that we'll be
focusing on today the cruciatus curse
also known as simply the torture curse
the cruciatus curse is used by saying
the word crucio then the Wizarding World
it has a reputation as one of the
darkest spells as it causes unimaginable
pain to its victim in fact the suffering
endured at the hand of this curse is so
intense and Powerful that it typically
results in the victim becoming
permanently Afflicted mentally or
physically if they are subjected to it
for prolonged periods of time with the
primary usage of the cruciatus curse in
mind the etymology about the name of the
curse itself as well as the incantation
for the spell make complete sense for
cruciatus and crucio are both derived
from Latin words with crucier meaning to
torture and crucio translating to eye
torture if I may be so bold there's
certainly no hidden meaning behind any
of that but where did the cruciatus
curse come from who created it and more
importantly why from what we know the
curse was developed in the Early Middle
Ages by witches and wizards who are
involved in the dark arts it was
initially designed for the same usage as
in modern times to torture others which
aligns well with the common practice of
torture that was performed by Muggles
during medieval times it's also been
noted that some witches and wizards made
use of the cruciatus curse during duels
to give them a Competitive Edge from an
exchange between Bellatrix Australian
Harry Potter during the battle of the
Department of mysteries we know that in
order to work properly the curse must be
cast with a deep desire to cause harm to
the victim and that the Caster must also
derive a sense of pleasure from
inflicting pain on another person this
becomes evident after Harry tries to
cast the curse at Bellatrix and the
effects wear off almost instantly
Bellatrix then cries at Harry never used
an unforgivable curse before have you
boy you need to mean them Potter you
need to really want to cause pain to
enjoy it righteous anger won't hurt me
for long I'll show you how it's done
shall I despite its dark and Despicable
nature the curse was quite popular for
many hundreds of years within the
Wizarding World until its eventual ban
in the 18th century with the development
of the official governing body the
British Ministry of Magic the cruciatus
curse along with the killing curse and
the imperious curse were dubbed the
unforgivable curses and made it legal in
the year 1717. the three cast were
legalized again throughout the years but
only during times of war and extreme
conflict during Voldemort's first rise
to power the head of the Department of
magical law enforcement bartimius Crouch
senior lifted the ban on the curses in
an effort to level the playing field for
the ministry's auras against the Dark
Lord's Death Eaters who had little issue
with breaking the law to use the
unforgivable curses in the name of
Voldemort and it was during Voldemort's
second rise to power in the 1990s that
the three curses were once again
legalized This Time by the dark lord
himself after he overtook the ministry
of magic as I'm sure you've realized the
majority of those who cast the cruciatus
curse are dark witches and wizards most
notably Voldemort and his Death Eaters
at least in recent history typically the
curse is performed on people of both
magical and muggled Ascent but that said
it can be cast onto any living creature
like we see in the Goblet of Fire when
the fake Madame Moody demonstrates the
curse on a spider due to the Criminal
Intent most of the witches and wizards
who have utilized the cruciata's curse
not to mention the extreme harm it
causes to victims it likely comes as no
surprise that casting this spell is
punishable by life imprisonment if
caught using this or either of the other
two unforgivable curses the witch or
wizard who casts it would be promptly
arrested and sent to the magical prison
of Azkaban to live out the remainder of
their life outside of the years that the
cruciatus curse was legalized the only
way to avoid imprisonment was if a witch
or wizard could cast this Bell could
provide enough evidence to suggest that
they were under the influence of the
imperious curse at the time of casting
crucio when it comes to defending
against this heinous curse there's
little the intended victim can do once
the Caster of the spell has uttered the
incantation in fact there's no known
spell that can properly defend against
it the only way one can actually avoid
the effects of the cruciatus cat us
after it has been cast is to physically
avoid or evade the spell a witch or
wizard could also avoid the effects of
the curse by simply interrupting the
Caster before they finish saying crucio
as Severus Snape did to Harry in the
Half-Blood Prince in addition to Harry's
attempt to use the cruciatus curse on
Professor Snape after the tragic death
of Albus Dumbledore this unforgivable
curse actually shows up quite frequently
after its introduction in the Goblet of
Fire as mentioned we first learn about
this and the other two curses in a Mad
Eye Moody imposters defense against a
dark arts class we then learn about one
of the most infamous cases to take place
in the last century involving the
cruciatus curse which targeted the
parents of never Longbottom Harry's
friend and Hogwarts classmate soon after
the fake Moody teaches the class about
this curse Professor Dumbledore shares
with Harry that Frank and Alice
Longbottom were tortured at the point of
insanity after being interrogated with
the cruciatus curse by Death who were
searched for Voldemort after he lost his
powers in 1981. tragically the long
bottoms never recovered and were
ultimately moved to Saint mungo's
Hospital for Magical maladies and
injuries to live out their lives there
since they could no longer care for
themselves or their son Neville of
course Harry later experiences the
effects of the cruciatus curse first
hand at the Wonder Voldemort himself
during the Dark Lord's rebirth in the
little hangleton graveyard it was pain
beyond anything Harry had ever
experienced his very bones were on fire
his head was surely splitting along his
scar he wanted it to end to black out to
Die the unforgivable curses were then
openly practiced and performed on
students at Hogwarts during the second
Wizarding War these lessons were led by
Professor Amicus Caro in which students
were not only taught the curse but
required to practice it on one another
in that same year birthrix Lestrange
also performed the cruciata's curse on
Hermione Granger during her interim
Nation at Malfoy Manor within the wider
Wizarding World we've also seen much use
of this unforgivable curse with the Alec
Grindelwald using it on muggle Jacob
Kowalski and the Fantastic Beasts series
not to mention the entire backstory
revolving around the cruciata's curse in
the newly released video game Hogwarts
Legacy and with that we've come to the
end of another video what did you think
did I miss anything of great importance
on the history of crucio and the
cruciatus curse please share your
thoughts in the comments below and as
always if you enjoyed this video don't
forget to like it and subscribe to the
channel until next time remember it does
not do to dwell on dreams and forget to
live